spandy work washington journal continues
we want to welcome back robber in
Farzana and who has been covering
business and finance issues for a number
of years appreciate you being with us
thank you Steve thanks Mary Bloomberg
News and we want to talk about this new
book by Michael Lewis which has been
getting a lot of attention I want to
share with you and our audience in just
a moment what he said yesterday on book
TV c-span - but explain what is this
phenomenon this idea of high frequency
trading which has been there is
exploiting putting putting out millions
of trades hundreds of thousands of
trades through milliseconds to exploit
minut movements if you throw enough
money at it if you throw enough volume
at it you can make a ton of money in
theory it's like scraping the dregs of
the market it's almost like a parasitic
behavior but markets have become so big
and so liquid the idea is that it's a
victimless crime there there's
technology and algorithms exploiting
this and people aren't getting hurt and
sophisticated hedge funds and traders
make money but Michael Lewis is out
there saying that no in fact this
destabilizes the market and it's a it's
a rigged system it lets a very wealthy
select few benefit at the expense the
literal expense of the majority of the
investing public the book is titled
flash boys a Wall Street revolt and
here's what Michael Lewis said yesterday
on c-span two's book TV great question
so I think parties so I us I one of the
questions I asked myself when I was
writing this story was what you always
ask this question why is this story
available to be written
why isn't there been more outrage about
this subject and it wasn't that it
wasn't that nobody had noticed that like
the exchange something was weird was
happening the stock market a lot of
people had noticed and insiders had
really noticed and it wasn't it every
now and then someone had not cried out
about it they were there were some
gadflies in the industry and critics in
the industry but it was it was that
people were numbed the public generally
was numbed and I think people inside the
markets were numbed by two things one in
the course of the story the stock
markets been booming so whatever a grift
there is whatever skin
there is isn't really noticeable in the
grande con in the context of a market
that triples from the financial crisis
everybody's making money so they so they
aren't thinking very much about like is
this sound' but the second thing is his
point which is it's in between the lines
of what he's quiz question is that when
it's done by a computer people have it's
not just deniability they have a sense
that like nobody a there isn't willful
human action behind it it's like just
the computer didn't the computer is
doing it and they also they also have a
level of complexity that's hard to parse
to actually understand the front-running
and to prove it kind of thing you
actually will need to parse the
algorithms written by high frequency
traders so it creates a smokescreen and
it creates I think an eternal moral
defense in a funny way that if you were
directing a computer to do something you
you will a person I think a human being
will direct your computer to do
something that they would never do
themselves if they were actually had to
physically do it as he tries to explain
exactly what this phenomena is how
prevalent is it from your standpoint
oh it's massive this is uh you know
markets have had a tumultuous decade
coming from the dot-com crash to the era
of scandals a lot of individual
investors tuning out and then of course
the culmination with the financial
crisis and as people were checking out
and Wall Street was kind of finding
itself in this period of rolling
scandals there is this huge dilemma out
there how do we keep up trading volumes
how do we offer something how do we keep
the most valued institutional investors
engaged so that they pay us commissions
and giving them access giving them event
letting them avail themselves of
preferred technology of even
split-second faster access to orders
ahead of big block trades from the likes
of fidelity and tiro price and the
Vanguard's and the other big mutual
funds that serve investors that is a way
of offering an edge and of course that
dance is on the line of illegality which
is a great wall street tradition going
back to the nineteen
is this idea that if you can go right up
to the edge of what's wrong and what's
malfeasance until regulators catch up
and and maximize that arbitrage then
you're fine just as long as you don't
find yourself in jail if you're not too
egregious with what you're doing let me
get your reaction to the comment of
Felix Sam and he writes for Reuters in
this opinion piece he says he's halfway
through the new Michael Lewis book and
he had watched that what he called the
breathless 60 Minutes segment but he
adds that the narrative is interesting
enough but so far I haven't seen
anything that would qualify as lightning
in a bottle as he had promised it's the
guy's got to sell books and he's a darn
good author and he gets Wall Street he's
a veteran of Wall Street he was there
through several eras he's covered
everything from the bond trading
scandals of the early 80s and the junk
bond pirates to subprime and now this
this crime this I this this idea of this
up malfeasance that's been happening
it's a great time to be able to invoke
something like Wall Street is rigged
because even though markets are at an
all-time high investor sentiment remains
in the dumps and if you could throw out
a charge like this on 60 minutes you're
going to get a ton of media appearances
and sell a ton of books but again I
think the onus is on him
Michael Lewis and the people who are
backing him for example the white hat
good guy firm that's countering the
high-frequency traders to actually prove
that investors are being hurt and I
haven't seen that yet what does this
mean for the individual investor you
know not much what is the individual
investors is not like it was decades ago
where you'd call your broker and you'd
pay a year regulated 150 dollar
Commission to buy a bunch of shares of
IBM or coca-cola a lot of people are
passively involved right now they're
involved in their 401ks and their Roth
IRAs the more that they're in index
funds and and paying even ever lower
cost you've seen a huge shift to the
vanguards to the ETF managers of the
world like black rocks and so people
aren't calling daily their brokers and
saying buy me this sell me this to the
point that they're going to cross paths
with these nefarious high-frequency
traders and get skimmed on a daily level
but this is one of those crimes like
even if you're talking about each
transaction being a fraction of a penny
you multiply that times billions of
transactions it's like the office space
caper the in the great thing called
classic 1999 movie you know it's a tiny
victimless fractional crime but
multiplied endless amounts it's actually
a big amount of money and that's the
idea that's going on here so I'm looking
like a parasitic thing you take a tiny
bit from every individual investor in
theory and it benefits a handful of
greedy kind of nefarious high-frequency
traders in theory in practice we haven't
seen that Politico is also writing about
this and the headline is the Michael
Lewis factor pointing out that Michael
Lewis has another hit on his his hands
before there was enough time for anyone
in Washington or a Wall Street to finish
reading flash boys the uproar was
already flooding in from all corners of
money in politics and the regulatory
establishment including this from on
Friday as the Attorney General Eric
Holder testified before our House
Appropriations Subcommittee also weighed
in on the thesis behind Michael Lewis's
book in the financial sector concerns
have been raised recently about a
practice called high-frequency trading
this practice which consists of
financial brokers and trading firms
using advanced computer algorithms and
ultra-high speed data networks to
execute trades has rightly received
scrutiny from regulators I can confirm
that we at the United States Department
of Justice are investigating this
practice to determine whether it
violates insider trading laws the
department is committed to ensuring the
integrity of our financial market
markets and we are determined to follow
this investigation wherever the facts
and the law may lead our last Friday
robbing cars had and over the weekend
USA Today confirming that the Justice
Department not only looking to
high-frequency trading but also trying
to figure out where the investigation is
going to lead them can you answer that
it's a great tradition you know
regulators slamming the barn door shut
when the horse is dead this is this is
something that's been going on for years
and the lawmakers are only now trying to
get their arms around this after all
sarbanes-oxley which is still being
implemented is dealing with a lot of the
after-effects of the last crisis and
there wasn't a lot of anticipation there
there are very few people that stood
before the steps of Capitol Hill in the
mid middle part of the last decade
saying we must follow sub-prime we must
we must look at securitization of what
Wall Street is doing and this is gonna
blow up and subsume the entire economy
and now you're having some of the
protagonists and Michael Lewis's book
saying that we have to be out there not
just for the insider trading aspect
which which could be sold as a kind of a
victimless crime but the idea that these
guys could be destabilizing the entire
market for all of us we saw a taste of
it with the flash crash in spring of
2010 which still hasn't been fully you
know post-mortems exactly what happened
if these guys something-something
overruns the computers much like we saw
in the crash of 1987 you're going to see
immediately Congress issue a ton of
subpoenas the next day like what's going
on wait flash traders i high-frequency
traders explain this and panel a
blue-ribbon group of experts on it so
there's this idea right now especially
while markets are saying when the
economy seems to be improving to get
ahead of a problem if it in fact poses a
risk to the integrity of our capital
markets bottom line what is your
takeaway of the book it's a great read
I love how Michael Lewis can demystify
very boring things I wouldn't want to
read a book about high frequency trading
per se but the fact that this is like a
he's always a stranger in a strange land
and the unlikely guy on Wall Street and
he meets these people you know if it
were if it weren't for the protagonist
in his book going out there saying I'm
creating a firm to counter the bad
effects of what these these guys with
the black hats are doing he wouldn't
necessarily have more than an article
here but you have a really riveting book
it makes it's a great page-turner I
don't know if there is exactly a
bonafide scandal or crisis in the making
Robin Farzad who is written for
Bloomberg the New York Times The Boston
Globe and the Wall Street Journal
graduate of Princeton and Harvard
Business School we're gonna get to your
calls in comments to 0 to 5 8 5:30 and
81 is our line for Republicans into 0 to
5 8 5:30 and 82 for Democrats we also
align for independence and you can weigh
in on our Twitter page including this
from Jim who says the business channels
refer to hft as front-running can you
explain what this means to the average
viewer yeah suppose your
you're finding out that a massive firm
like fidelity is about to put in a huge
sell order of you know say IBM shares a
huge liquid share you can get ahead of
that you can you can find out that
information you can piggyback on that
trade and sell your position for more
than ostensibly what a giant liquidation
order would do to move that price down
around the other hand if you're if
you're finding out a big firm like tiwa
price or Vanguard is gonna buy a ton of
stock that's gonna move the stock higher
if you get in even in a split second
ahead of that first part of that block
trade you stand to benefit so coming
like this is parasitic piggybacking
Charles Schwab Uncle Chuck the elder
statesman of the individual investors
right now actually he put out a great
statement this week calling
high-frequency trading a spreading
cancer he thinks that it's a serious
problem and it's not just parasitic
we're talking about destabilizing the
entire system sickening the entire
system from Richmond Virginia Charles is
on the phone good morning with Robin
Farhad yeah good morning listen to what
he's saying
but it happens in trading and the way to
use the computers was supposed to that
was supposed to stop all these different
crashes and stuff but wait a minute it's
really easy when when I be going now all
my work I listen to the UH to uh
publican radio and I see the stock
market was three hundred up three
hundred points in one day and then and
then all of a sudden got two hundred and
three are two hundred may be points or
maybe one hundred I said I say to myself
that's okay somebody's lost a lot of
money and we saw that on Friday with a
significant drop not only on the Dow but
also the Nasdaq if they're more sellers
than buyers the market Falls you know
this is a it happens an in lockstep it
happens over time that generally markets
tend to go up and that's the question
here our markets so distorted are they
so overrun by people looking to put in
these ephemeral meaningless trades to
exploit split-second opportunities that
do they no longer represent corporate
Americans
corporate America's profits and growth
so there's no longer the reliable proxy
for investors to put their retirement
accounts in their kids 529 money in I
don't see that being the case I think
that the market is still tracking
corporate profits corporate profits are
still near an all-time high even Michael
Lewis when you put his hand to the fire
or some of the other people were invoked
here there's like no I still invest in
index funds I don't think that the
markets broken I'm arguing that he's
arguing that some people are really
benefiting at the expense of others a
key player Mary Jo white who is the
chair of the Securities and Exchange
Commission what does this mean for her
the SEC still has a lot to prove after
missing the Bernie Madoff Bunco in 2008
when there were so many people in
hindsight they were crying bloody murder
in 2006-2007 Ponzi scheme Ponzi scheme
the SEC wants to get ahead of these
things right now it's been very vigilant
with enforcement actions if you look at
its New York bureau if you look at the
Attorney General in New York that
there's this idea of almost investigate
first ask questions later
and it's a it's an esoteric thing it's
it's not exactly transparent you know
you talk about the book a dedicated
fiber-optic cable being built between
New Jersey in the Midwest just for these
traders it's almost like this late 19th
century robber baron desk thing to do
you do it in secrecy but if you can
build the fastest fiber-optic cable that
can be a split second faster than the
network that the conventional trading
Clearing House puts out there then you
have a multi-billion dollar advantage
it's worth your while to build that so
you have to staff up you have to arm up
the SEC has to pay for talent that Wall
Street competes with to go out there to
track these crimes to understand the the
nature let's not call it a crime yet the
the architecture of what's being done
out there and if in fact there is
criminal behavior William Mills says of
course the stock market is fixed anyone
just figuring that out haven't been
paying any attention you know in the
Steve cropper report from last Sunday on
60 minutes he made an observation that
many people may not have thought of
before which is when we see the scenes
on CNBC or Fox Business channel from
lower Manhattan what's happening there
is really just a small very small piece
of where the trading is taking place yes
Wall Street is a psychographic term I
mean lower Manhattan is you know the
this the floor trader is on the New York
Stock Exchange they used to mean much
more than they do now a lot of these
things are happening by and large the
the bidders and the the buyers and
sellers are being matched with very
efficient computers and a hand handful
of brokers and electronic exchanges and
multinational ownership and the question
I mean by and large I mean Jack Bogle
who's the founder of the Vanguard group
and one of the elder statesmen as well
for the individual investors saying that
high-frequency trading has also helped
the individual investor by relentlessly
pushing down trading costs I mean
commissions have become such a commodity
since they were deregulated in the early
70s and used to be prohibitive to go out
there and buy a stock now a lot of
brokerage firms you know they aren't
even charging you for certain ETFs are
charging you nominal $2 commissions if
you want to buy stocks with them and
this has been helped by the fact that
there are these ephemeral traders out
there willing to pay for millions of
trades at a time so there's a good side
effect to what they're doing so at this
point if high frequency trading does add
volume and that means liquidity one day
doesn't that create volatility the next
yes that's that's the question that if
we see some sort of gumming up of the
works let's go back I mean people forget
the crash of 87 was a failure an
electronics failure there were there
were there were stops in the system and
volume is a fraction a sliver of what we
see today and what happens when all of
these lines potentially get crossed to
get a y2k type moment I don't want to
think about it necessarily but we have
to we saw a taste of it something did go
wrong with the flash crash of 2010 and
the Dow dropped a thousand points and
then recovered it a bunch of people got
hurt when they sold stocks on false
information people I remember that day
they were worried that BP was going to
go bankrupt when something like that
happens there's this massive echo
chamber especially when you consider
24-hour news Twitter now the the huge
echo chamber effective news today and
you talk about how how much more
sophisticated massive institutions are
but when you talk about volume being so
long
millions of trades done in milliseconds
then there's a potential for a calamity
and I think that's worrying regulators
more than the malfeasance aspect right
now our guest is Robin Farzad he covers
business and finance issues and for
nearly a decade
writing for Bloomberg News now a new
venture yeah I was with Business Week
but I will be launching a radio show
soon called full disclosure which will
cover business and economics and finance
and we'll have the website up soon and
so help me God it works let's go to Andy
joining us from East Rutherford New
Jersey and good morning thanks for
waiting hey good morning guys I'd like
to see a transaction tax
I think it's been called a half a cent
per trade would add up quickly and
anyone who claims to care about the
deficit I think could get behind this
thank you okay we'll get a response and
thanks for listening on c-span radio
okay it's a great idea being floated
around this idea that if you can't bar
it illegally it's this form of you know
markets are liquid people can buy and
sell and you can't borrow computers from
doing these things even if they're
ephemeral trades even if these people
don't have a conviction between the buy
and sell if they're just agnostic and
following an algorithm that should be
taxed because that behavior could be
deleterious to the rest of us if they
increase volatility if they increase
fragility in the system and potentially
destabilize it there should be a tax
that decended behavior and if it's going
to happen generate some revenue in the
meantime for the government we're
talking about the issue of high
frequency trading and now the
announcement last Friday by the Justice
Department and Attorney General Eric
Holder that an investigation is now
underway
Michael Lewis and his new book featured
on c-span 2's book TV over the weekend
in case you missed it it's available
online at c-span org the book is titled
flash boys and one of our viewers saying
it's only a matter of time before hft
high frequency trading triggers another
flash crash and the next financial
mushroom cloud erupting from Wall Street
let's go to New York
Robert is on the phone independent line
good morning good morning
you trying to answered my question while
I was on vote so I want to ask who built
these who are the high-frequency traders
and who built the networks
it's an agglomeration of technology
people quants mathematicians spin-offs
from brokerage firms and specialist
shops after all these are people that
used to employ floor traders specialists
on the floor the New York Stock Exchange
they've seen Commission's compressed
over time you go from fractional trades
to decimalisation it's being
relentlessly relentlessly pushed down so
you have to you're under enormous
pressure to offer an edge and if that's
technology and the confluence of
technology and information even if it's
a split second edge in information
before the feds catch up to it before
it's declared as expressly illegal then
it's a it's a great loophole to exploit
it happening instantaneously very very
fast faster than the blink of an eye in
the fraction of a blink of an eye are we
seeing this in Europe and Asian markets
less so in Europe I believe in Italy for
example there's a lot that Italy has
such a rip-roaring equity market or
trading scene but there's a tax on on
this kind of trading on on this kind of
speculation because this idea that you
have people speeding if you look at if
you look at our market liquidity and the
trades that happen on all exchange is an
aggregate us volume in a day that's like
a superhighway in the United States and
you have these people that are whizzing
on it in these 120 mile per hour
Lamborghinis and the rest of us in our
minivans and Subarus and this idea but
that should be dissuaded it should be
made potentially outright illegal if
they're going to have special lanes to
do this that they should pay a cost for
servicing these lanes and for the risk
that is presented to everybody else you
know I run out of metaphors to explain
it because if it is happening with the
nefariousness mission with mr. Lewis
kind of alleges that it's happening then
it's another one of these perfect crimes
emanating from this big bad boogeyman
that's Wall Street I mean even in this
period of penance and reflection for the
subprime transgressions the fact that
this is happening in earnest the fact
that these trades are multiplying in
volume I think if we look back on this
in three or four years and say wow this
was happening and these guys got away
with it I will have been amazed Joe
makes this point saying a transaction
tax would [ __ ] the
market and this is from Carl Richards at
the New York Times who has another
metaphor making this a mountain out of a
molehill saying that what Michael Lewis
is writing about is an issue but Michael
Lewis is making this far bigger again
our markets not functioning do they not
Rick do they not reflect underlying
corporate health in this country markets
are again they're near an all-time high
the stock market last year the S&P 500
was up 30% the economy has recovered
it's reflect the SEC and reflected the
fact that that banks are are capitalized
if if they become so distorted like the
Chinese market Chinese stock market for
example which is very poorly regulated
which has not tracked GDP growth very
well there's looked at as the province
of speculators and reckless ephemeral
types that come in and come out and is
not a good proxy for corporate growth
there then I would I would be worried
but having said all this it's a real
pungent time again to be able to cry
something to the effect of the market is
rigged because people are coming off of
a twice bitten thrice tri period with
the stock market if the market is at an
all-time high and participation relative
to that has not been at lows that we've
seen I think since the late 1990s then
you this is a great time to write a book
like this this idea of taxing these
trades getting a lot of interest from
our viewers and from our listeners
sending in these tweets hft should be
taxed not to dissuade it but because
these guys make no other positive
contribution to their country is the
idea of taxing these trades something
that Congress potentially could take up
they could it's hard to find any
unanimity up on that great hill for any
sort of tax increase any sort of tax
hike you would sooner see other
prohibitions put in either making this
absolutely illegal or having so many
different smell tests that you'd have to
go through that makes it prohibitive for
this to happen ultimately you're going
to see I think another situation like
the flash crash of 2010 put this in
sharp relief it's bound to happen as the
volumes multiplied as people are still
leery of coming back to a mark
that even if Michael Lewis didn't put
out this book a lot of people with the
memory of the bailouts of 2008 and 2009
and private profits and socialized risk
and subprime securities that alone has a
lot of people sitting outside and
remaining on the sidelines we'll go to
Debbie joining us from Scranton
Pennsylvania good morning Democrats line
hiya
I just really have a statement to say
you know put forth I've actually worked
in Manhattan and I've done some auditing
at both financial institutions like s AC
and Kalyan etc and every time I hear
something like this I think that it
continues to undermine the respect and
Trust the citizens of this country have
their government and I really like the
term mushroom cloud because I'm looking
at that and I'm thinking that when we
allow Wall Street to do or participate
in this type of activity I think it's
actually a threat to our national
security because we're not making any
friends okay and so somebody needs to
reel these guys in and of course it's
not fair because if it was fair then
they wouldn't be doing it Debbie thanks
for the call and Jim makes this point
Steve please inform the viewers that
these earnings are taxed as regular
income and thereby these folks do
contribute all in Farsad that is true I
mean this is an enormous regular income
stuff these are short-term profit gains
and that these happen and that they're
levied and profits are taxed at enormous
levels should be a check alone on this
happening but it's not the idea is that
if you put in another incremental tax a
penny for example on top of it it's
going to dissuade some of the more
reckless trades from Baldwinsville
Massachusetts Bob is on the phone good
morning my question is I know this
high-frequency trading is is some new
stuff for everybody to be hearing about
but how about our Senate and our House
of Representatives who have always had
inside information and make all kinds of
trades and stuff they come in semi rich
and leave billionaires thank Bob thanks
for the column that's being reined in
recently I think also thanks to another
60 minutes investigation I think it
speaks to
bigger issue in that this is asymmetric
warfare between regulators were at large
and Wall Street writ large that Wall
Street investing firms pension firms
trading firms hedge funds are always
going to be able to pay multiples more
for talent that regulators also need to
advise in order to stay on top of these
jigs if you don't want to call them
scams or crimes outright there's always
this idea that you you know in a system
where regulators are always looking to
catch up with investors and profit ears
that the side that can arm up more with
the with the brains and the quants is
going to win and indeed a lot of these
regulators when they're done a lot of
these representatives when they're done
with their terms go and work in the
private sector and advise some of these
financial institutions so it's a it's so
vexing ly difficult to regulate these
things in real time I think without
someone like Michael Lewis kind of
raising the bloody flag and going on
sixty minutes and and using colorful
language and metaphors and this
us-versus-them indignation it's it's so
hard for Wall Street to it's it's so
hard for Congress and for the SEC NASD
to give this stuff time of day when
there's so many other pressing issues
kiki makes this point I pay taxes to can
i Rob pensions question mark she asks
tongue-in-cheek well again it's the idea
that it's a victimless crime if you're
out there you're not flooding the market
with sell orders or buy orders at a time
if you have to take the consequences of
a loss it's a split second thing look
it's murky it's dark it's not as as kind
of Willie Sutton clear-cut as going in
and robbing a bank and that's kind of
what makes it beautiful this idea of a
perfect crime a victimless crime where
you defuse all sorts of responsibilities
and you're cover your fingerprints and
you blame the black box you blame the
Machine you blame the technology like
why is this a crime if we built a faster
fiber-optic network if we're there we
should be rewarded for our
infrastructure investment we built a
better mousetrap our guest is robbing
far zag we're focusing on high frequency
trading and an issue
is front and center because of the new
book by Michael Lewis who joined us
yesterday on c-span tunes book TV titled
flash boys and you can check it out
online at c-span dot-org also at book
tv.org John is joining us from Center
Ossipee New Hampshire good morning John
you with us I'll try one more time for
John we're gonna have to move on to
Elizabeth joining us from Maryland good
morning great Elizabeth hello yes you're
on the air yes good morning it is not a
victimless crime a victimless crime
because it has made other training 2nd
3rd and 4th tier because it's not based
on value it's not based on product it's
not based on the performance of the CEO
the CEO the CFO and it puts everyone
else a tinted image because it is truly
not through performance but just through
speed it is skimming the cream of the
cream of the cream that's right but from
their idea is that if we could do this
before regulators fully catch up and
fully tie our hands down that there's
there billions to be made so again this
cat-and-mouse game has been going on for
the entirety of the modern era of Wall
Street if you look at how certain
markets were cornered in the 1920s stock
pumping scams insider trading in the
1980s insider trading was bandied about
as a victimless crime too because after
all you know I I just get some
information I mean they're selling a
stock or buying a stock but of course
there's a person on the other end of
that transaction that doesn't have the
information that you do when you talk
about liquidity overall volume being a
kind of an ocean of trades and you have
high-frequency traders even for their
hundreds of millions of trades
representing maybe a pool inside that
ocean there's this idea that look
whatever we do isn't really disrupting
the entire ph of this ecosystem is not
really causing all that much of a ripple
in the end you know it's just a wash
Wall Street again trading firms are paid
to exploit arbitrage is that's why
people are out there saying that if
volumes are falling if active managers
incidentally are not doing well against
index funds this has not been a great
era for the Fidelity's for the for the
for the old stock fund managers of the
world what other advantage can we avail
ourselves of there's this idea that that
there's still a a timing advantage and a
and an information advantage that's a
split second information advantage that
has not yet been codified as illegal and
so dancing in the gray areas has been a
Wall Street tradition for time
immemorial which goes back to this
question from another viewer saying how
does the regular guy get into the racket
it's not easy for the regular Guardian
in the racket I mean a lot of this stuff
is black box and algorithm you know
quants from PhD programs are paid quite
a bit to develop models that that kind
of say if if this various rube goldberg
type situation happens and if then
scenario happens and we can have
something that goes in and rapidly buys
and sells this permutation of securities
or derivatives and however many blinks
of an eye then there is a fractional
advantage or risk-free advantage to be
made it's it's supposed to be so
esoteric that not even their own bosses
can understand it much less the head of
the Justice Department or your
congressman from middle America our
guest is moving from Bloomberg News in
Business Week to a new radio program
full disclosure which will premiere at
the end of the month this is from this
is from Ron in Sacramento how much
effect does this have on the price of a
transaction there's there's really no
effect on the price of a transaction in
fact like as I said before Jack Bogle
was out there pooh-poohing the Michael
Lewis book is saying that this is a this
has helped individual investors out
there people who used to think that it
was a great deal to pay a $30 Commission
we're recently paying $9 commissions are
now paying to $3 Commission's because a
large party who these high-frequency
trading firms come in and and
relentlessly make a commission a
commodity and everybody else has been
having to push down their costs Denise
is joining us from Lincoln Park New
Jersey Democrats line good morning what
are you interested in the circuit was
just brought to my attention by an MBA
student this week on Twitter I think
what this is really done and it's
extremely dangerous is it out sourced I
think you speaker has alluded to it it's
outsourced the role of the floor trader
in the floor broker because no one can
compete against a massive orders coming
in on a computer line and so Wall Street
has squeezed out another whole sector of
employees and replaced them by
computerized trading the ramifications
of what this could mean if there's
another precious really no one's a place
used to be that you would call your
broker your broker would know the feel
of what's going on in the market
execute the orders based on their
experience this is all gone and there's
really very few brokers that are
executing trades they're all
computerized trades I would like to hear
what the author has the speaker has to
say about these really the outsourcing
of those positions on Wall Street and
forward to seeing your radio show
sounds very you just think tell me where
it's gonna be a right to hear it up but
I would like to hear your comment about
elimination of all these employees for
the sake of increasing profits like
everything else from this country thanks
so much bye-bye
well thank you I think it's tempting to
kind of cause-effect these situations
right there the the extinction of the
floor trader the new york stock exchange
specialist and the takeover of these
these heartless automatron ik robots but
there's an inevitability in that much
the same way that we had to say bye to
the milkman and the buggy whip this
stuff was going to be automated it's
just a heck of a lot more efficient to
match a notion of varying bid and ask
orders through computers much the same
way that people rely on
internet communication much more than
they do the US Postal Service right now
or telegrams or sending money orders
over Western Union a lot of this stuff
was going to go away before we had
high-frequency trading so having said
that on a day where there is something
like a flash crash and believe it was
May of 2010 it does put in sharp relief
how important is to have human eyes and
ears there when the system is gummed up
when when how in 2001 for example
malfunctions you need to have human
beings be able to go out there and
exercise judgment and say look put a
halt on the orders here and let's use
our eyes and ears to sense what's going
wrong and and disable that and and get
trading done and have an efficient
effective market for the balance of the
day and I think that's why you're never
going to see the full end of the floor
trader on the New York Stock Exchange
you're going to see computerization of
trading happen it's happened the world
over it's made it possible for us to buy
and sell shares after hours on overseas
exchanges but there's always going to be
a need for a human touch I don't think
they'll ever fully put those guys out of
business a couple of points this is a
tweet from one of our viewers who says
the real scandal the use of government
intelligence information to trade in
markets and this from Peter in
Shrewsbury England watching us on the
BBC Parliament Channel just wondering if
high-frequency trading
though negative and destructive to a
domestic economy could it be turned into
a benefit to a country by transforming
it into an economic weapon of economic
warfare oh gosh the extent that the
systems are being computerised
relentlessly and we're talking about
micro second advantages a high-frequency
trade used to be something that took a
couple of seconds just until a few years
ago you talk about the system overall
becoming a lot more fragile and if that
is attacked by cyber terrorists or an
external force that figures out how to
throw the big monkey wrench into it that
could conceivably cause an economic
panic
our topic Wall Street and the new book
by Michael Lewis flash boys and it is
is from 19 California good morning
morning my question is to the reporter
that that you don't think this is a
national possibility against our
national security because they're all
it's always it's already a gap between
equality and daily lives of United
States citizens that don't have jobs and
put their pensions into these companies
and they invest them into Wall Street
and we're those people that get hurt
they move our pensions in our 401k and
while you and the rest of you guys
there's hierarchy get all the benefits
all the inside and you won't even do
justice to to report on it honestly and
a bipartisan way where you are not
budding up with the wall street people
in the hedge funds and they'll CEO that
you work for that you can't even be the
common decency to tell us
oh gosh if I if I work for these guys I
wouldn't be wearing a blazer like this
but look I understand the indignation
income inequality is especially bad
right now unemployment is high we're
coming off of a period of record job
losses and the market that that is soon
and uneven results coming out of that
and the rich have benefited
disproportionately as asset prices have
improved as junk bonds and stocks as
real estate and the wealthier people
have disproportionately allowed to we're
able to be involved in in these assets
more didn't have to liquidate them but I
disagree with the idea that this is a
kind of a buddy up cozy cozy up
situation and that the system is
necessarily rigged I think that markets
still work I think that I am in index
funds my colleagues aren't index funds
my professors are in index funds we
reinvest the proceeds we don't look at
the results we don't day trade we don't
flash trade we don't get too euphoric
when everybody is excited we don't get
too despondent
when everybody is throwing the babies
out with the bathwater and if you stay
that course over time I think you're
going to do well after all it takes I
think with dividends and everything
included something like seven and a half
percent compound and to double your
money every ten years and ten years
especially when you're talking about a
lost decade for the stock market in the
2000s a is a long time but if people
were diversified through that flash
crash high frequency trading scandals
Enron WorldCom subprime and all they
would have done well and they would have
stuck with it so don't let your
indignation and the conspiracy
theorizing get so much of the best of
you that you forget that in the end this
is a this is a steady wins the race game
investing in preparing for your
retirement I want to encourage our
viewers and listeners to watch the
interview with Michael Lewis that we
conducted yesterday on c-span 2's book
TV it is available online at book TV org
and also c-span org this is the cover
flash boys robbing far as I had what
impact do you think this book will have
here in Washington and in New York you
don't get people interested in a Wall
Street again I mean this is a this is an
information economy there's you know
right now I'd say for the past month or
two people have been decidedly much more
interested in international affairs and
what's been going on in Russia and
Crimea and capital markets have you know
the five-year anniversary of the crash
of 2008 has kind of come and gone and
people can't believe that markets keep
breaking an all-time high every day but
this idea that if regulators can finally
get ahead of the next jig ahead of the
next scam might actually be irresistible
to several lawmakers especially because
the this thing's of the last crash are
still so so painful Robin Farr is dad
who is written for Bloomberg News and
Businessweek his byline also seen for
the New York Times in the Wall Street
Journal and now moving to radio the
program is titled full disclosure
appreciate you being with us thank you
Steve appreciate it
we're gonna take a short break and when
we come back we're going to turn our
attention to the voting in Afghanistan
Michael O'Hanlon will be joining us he's
an expert on the region a senior fellow
at Brookings and also the Senate will be
later this week two extended jobless
benefits will be getting